[Musique]
aujourd'hui jeudi 26 avril c'est le duo
d une journée particulière au cours de
laquelle une personne en situation de
handicap se retrouvent en immersion dans
une entreprise
accompagné d'un tuteur le département
profite de l'événement pour organiser
une matinée de rencontres et d échanges
avec les acteurs de l'insertion et le
monde du handicap parce que c'est celui
là qui permettra à un plus grand nombre
de travailleurs handicapés d'être dans
l'emploi en situation de d'exercer
pleinement leurs capacités
professionnelles leur force
professionnels de travailler dans des
entreprises avec leurs différences et de
ne pas être stigmatisés et les messages
qu'on a pu entendre 10 au moins une
chose c'est que derrière chacun d'entre
nous handicapé ou pas il y a une force
qui est réel et c'est cette force là
qu'il faut regarde et enrichissant parce
que justement chaque partenaire peut
déjà dire définir son rôle
l'évolution est bien sûr l'avenir de
studios day dans les années à venir mais
comme je disais aussi il faut pas
attendre en dur day pour en parler
on peut le chaque personne peut aider
une personne en situation de handicap
chaque jour de sa vie
une journée nationale pour comprendre et
dépasser les préjugés à la réunion
quarante mille personnes sont en
situation de handicap est confronté à
des difficultés d'accès à l'emploi
les binômes du diodé au département bien
compris les enjeux de cette journée
ça représente une chance de rentrer
dans le monde du travail et
de voir comment ça se passe dans une
entreprise
pouvoir intégrer le département c'est
une possibilité qui me crispait au 8
août à crulai bien je trouve que c'est
une grande chance pour vous de pouvoir
justement aider les personnes en
situation de handicap
il faut savoir que voilà souvent ces
personnes sont malheureusement rejetée
on hésite en fait à avoir un
un binôme porteurs de handicap donc du
coup moi je tombe et c'est une chance
une chance à la fois pour camille
chancel à toi pour moi de pouvoir
justement découvrir de nouvelles
personnes
et justement ils ont aussi dû donner de
nouvelles perspectives en fait une belle
opportunité déjà de rencontrer donc une
nouvelle personne d'être essayé
d'apporter en fait un petit peu ce que
j'ai fait un peu de savoir faire et puis
c'est vrai qu'à personnes en fait qui
est qui et qui avec nous aujourd'hui
c'est personne qui a des compétences
donc elle qui s'est aussi souvent ce
qu'elle veut et j'ai donné juste le des
leviers
les moyens peut-être d'accès d'un emploi
plus tard donc je pense que c'est une
très bonne opportunité
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses pendant
la conférence tous les organismes tout
ça les différents organismes dans lequel
on peut on peut être aidé et franchement
très bonne idée
chef de file de la politique liée au
handicap le département s'engage
pleinement dans cette journée du duo dé
6,5 pour cent des agents de la
collectivité sont en situation de
handicap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]